seit jahrhunderten ist ihr eines der
lieblingsgetränke in der schweiz heute
wird es zunehmend auch dort produziert
doch von wem und warum ich habe vier
bier das groupie des 3,8 das ballett und
unser ip mit diskus aus der brauerei
haben der auch ein rauchiges porter
an einem warmen sommertag machen wir uns
auf einen beer festival auf die suche
nach den geheimnissen des biers zu
vertreten
[Musik]
wenn man zum ersten mal probiert weil es
mein höchstens welche sorte es ist
braucht der ist sehr speziell man liebt
es oder man hasst es
jeder hersteller hat seine signatur
das gibt dem ganzen eine emotionale
komponente
es hängt oft im keller der eltern einer
werkstatt oder garage ab
wie bei steve jobs
steve jobs
[Musik]
alles fängt also in einer garage aber wo
steht die angeblich gibt es eine davon
den cognac
ich stand kurz vor dem ruhestand und
wollte etwas finden mit dem ich mich
beschäftigen kann damit ich nicht
ständig meiner frau auf die nerven gehen
[Musik]
wenn noch stärke drin ist wird es
dunkler
das bedeutet dass die stärke noch in
zucker umgewandelt wird bleibt die farbe
gleich ist die umwandlung abgeschlossen
wir sind eine gruppe eine kleine
kooperative und teilen uns kosten und
gebühren
in den vergangenen monaten sind neue
mitglieder dazu gestoßen die unsere
leidenschaft teilt es ist immer toll sie
zu treffen was wir mindestens alle zwei
monate tun
die reden dann den ganzen tag über alles
mögliche und tauschen uns darüber auch
etwas neues etwas kreatives zu
erschaffen
die genießen die gemeinsam verbrachte
zeit und natürlich steht auch die
verkostung der früchte unserer arbeiten
im mittelpunkt
[Musik]
tolle zitrusnoten
bist du was gutes nicht gut gemacht
[Gelächter]
insgesamt sind wir 9 bei den treffen
sind immer mindestens fünf oder sechs
tag
alles funktioniert blendend
drehen weiter drehen
[Musik]
wir haben schon erfolgreiche bier
hergestellt zb unser imperiali vom
januar
das war unser größter erfolg es erhielt
tolle bewertungen
[Musik]
unser jüngster streich war ein
schottisches tag das war auch sehr
interessant
das sind die spiele die wir gerne noch
mal braun
je nach jahreszeit machen wir auch biere
für feierlichkeiten oder auch mal
meditations- biere wie wir gerne sagen
die man am abend langsam genießt
und auch fröhliche biere für den sommer
wenn man nach einem langen spaziergang
richtig durst hat
wir brauchen die richtige menge
es ist ein tolles hobby das nicht allzu
viel zeit verschlingt wir entscheiden
selbst wenn wir uns treffen um einen
braut tag zu haben oder auch mal am
abend für eine verkostung
wir haben uns auch schon zum essen
getroffen und eine reise fast schon eine
pilgerfahrt nach belgien unternommen um
die uralte kultur dort kennenzulernen
das war faszinierend
möchtest du nicht probieren
[Musik]
meine hand macht das von allein und wir
müssen alle warten
ein schottisches ale
na dann prost
[Musik]
manchmal ist eine garage aber einfach zu
klein wer größere ambitionen hat nutzt
eine ehemalige autowerkstatt
wega nello hatten wir viel weniger platz
es war schon sehr interessant für uns da
wir zuvor auf unserem weg in dieses
abenteuer große rückschläge erlitten
hatten
letztendlich wurde unser traum in wigan
elfer wir wussten aber schon dass wir
diesen weiteren schritt gehen würden
aber wir haben es geschafft
hier traf noch andere bierhersteller
ich kam vor zwei jahren aus den usa
zurück vor meiner reise in die usa hatte
ich keinerlei interesse daran selbst
bier zu brauen
das kam erst dort auf und regte mich
auch nach meiner rückkehr
ich wollte die szene und die ganzen
brauereien hier interessieren und auch
in norditalien kennenlernen
[Musik]
eines abends lud ich ihn ein
wir merken gleich dass wir viel
gemeinsam hatten rodrigo hatte die
gleichen bücher bei sich zu hause wie
ich er sagte sofort ich habe genau die
gleichen bücher zu hause wir haben also
die gleiche bibliothek
genau auch was unsere einstellung zum
braun anging waren wir auf einer
wellenlänge und
zusammen zu tun war sie nur natürlich
wie habt ihr das finanziert
wir haben uns geld von meiner familie
geliehen das müssen wir auch noch
zurückzahlen
wir brauchen zwei jahre
es war nämlich schwieriger als erwartet
will man einen technologie startup für
die forschung gründen bekommt man von
überall her geld will man aber bier
brauen monieren sie es gäbe schon so
viele brauer interessieren warum sollte
man uns noch geld geben das hier ist die
lieferung von heute morgen was ist das
vier fermenter
der fermenter und ein reifen genau was
macht man damit
in den vier fermentern soll das bier
gehen wenn es fertig ist kommt es in den
reife tank und bleibt dort bis zur
abfüllung
es ist dann also fertig für abfüllung
verkauf und vertrieb
sie ergänzen unser gebrauchtes inventar
da hat mir nur zwei fermenter so können
wir jede woche mehr bier produzieren
contentad wie können die ab jetzt damit
herstellen und wann geht's los
etwa 3000 liter pro woche
beachtlich das sind 12.000 liter im
monat jetzt geht es also richtig los
jetzt sind wir richtig aufgestellt
unser traum nimmt nun endgültig gestalt
an vorher bis jetzt war alles nur ein
probelauf
tatsächlich sind mit der finanzierung
und dem kauf der geräte die probleme
noch nicht zu ende
fabio und rodrigo warten seit sechs
monaten auf die erlaubnis mit der
vollproduktion beginnen zu können
zwischenzeitlich haben sie ihre alten
arbeitsplätze gekündigt
aktuell machen sie keinen umsatz aber
sie haben mit ihrem projekt immer noch
ein klares ziel vor augen
wir wollen etwas neues machen neue
geschmäcker ausprobieren und dem dir
mehr charakter
in lugano findet man zwar in sachen bier
von allem etwas aber es wirkt immer noch
etwas verhalten
alles spielen lieber auf nummer sicher
wir wollen daher die stadt zumindest in
bezug auf ihr unkonventioneller und mit
einem raueren charme repräsentieren
das ist wohl auch der grund weshalb das
bier von fabio und rodrigo broken city
heißt gebrochene stadt ein
avantgardistischer name für ihr projekt
das wir kraft wir unüblich in dosen
verkauft wird und nicht unbedingt aus
regionalen rohstoffen gebraut wird
bei manchen unternehmen nicht nur bei
brauereien hat man das gefühl es geht
vor allem um den ortsbezug umzuziehen
auch für uns ist es wichtig dass wir uns
nur ghana sind das soll die seele
unserer brauerei seien aber für mich
steht im vordergrund dass wir gutes bier
brauen wollen
[Musik]
die leute sollen es trinken wollen unser
bier vor allem deshalb mögen weil es gut
ist nicht nur weil es aus tess ihren
kommt oder regional ist es sollte nicht
darauf reduziert werden leider wird
dieser aspekt oft stärker betont als
andere qualitäten
fabio columbo war uns tatsächlich
bereits begegnet
bitte sehr ebenso nicole becker
[Musik]
tolles fruchtiges aroma sehr erfrischend
schöne helle farbe und trübung im
vergleich zu anderen apps so wollen es
die meisten ja das ist die
charakteristische optik
nico ist ein experte in sachen bier und
hat sich in seiner heimat belgien und
auch in england zum thema bier
weitergebildet vor ein paar jahren zog
er nach tessin in der welt des kraft
beers ist er wohl bekannt sein rat und
seine meinungen sind hoch geschätzt und
genau das hier merkt man unterschiedlich
danke für das kompliment
ich glaube das beste bier ist immer dass
das war mit anderen teilt ich teile auch
mein wissen über bier gerne mit anderen
so lernen sie dass es viele verschiedene
biere gibt und für jeden die richtige
sorte dabei ist
man muss sich trauen mehr als ein bier
zu probieren auch wenn einem das erste
nicht schmeckt
was verbindet sie mit dem bier
es wird hier meistens als party getränk
oder durstlöscher gesehen nicht als
qualitativ hochwertiges geschmacks und
trinkt erlebnis das ändert sich aber bei
den verkostungen die ich veranstalte
gehen manche teilnehmer genau so
differenziert an das spiel heran wie sie
es von weinproben gewohnt waren
sobald sie all die nielsen die es bei
ihr gibt kennenlernen erschließt sich
ihnen eine ganz neue welt und sie können
die vielfalt des bieres entdecken
wir folgen nico und treffen so andere
bierbrauer aus tessin
[Musik]
folter mit kakao
und tabakblätter
ich bekam die idee für das bier als für
die warburg strafen und ein hierfür sie
machen wollten
es sollte ein dunkles bier mit
zusätzlich kakao und tabakblättern
werden denn sie lieben porter und
spielen es musste also dunkel sein und
ich zu stark um die 4,9 prozent angenehm
zu trinken
es ist ein gutes bier dass man das ganze
jahr lang genießen kann
ja schön sanft mit klarem weichen
geschmack
die gelegenheit für diese treffen ist
das lupo lahti ein festival das
verbrauchern zum vierten mal die
möglichkeit gibt kleine bierbrauer zu
treffen und auch als wettbewerb für
hobby braumeister dient die gerade erst
anfangen
[Musik]
an diesem tisch sitzen die juroren
experten mit einer fantastischen
leidenschaft für bier die zum ersten mal
dir für den tessiner hobby brauerei
wettbewerb probieren
es wird alles zu hause getraut nicht in
echten brauereien
die hobby braumeister kommen zu unserer
veranstaltung und warten auf das urteil
der experten
der sieger des ersten tessiner hobby
brauerei wettbewerbs ist martin albert
ii sein
imperial arctic potter hat uns alle
begeistert
alle die professionell bierbrauen haben
als hobby ersten angefangen wir brauchen
ist eine leidenschaft anfängt genauso in
der garage an wie steve jobs
alle machen am anfang nur kleine mengen
wahrscheinlich entstehen tatsächlich in
vielen garagen weltweit die biere und
trends von morgen wie auch die paarung
spezifischer speise mit dir etwas auf
dass nico sich sehr gut versteht
der klassiker ist sicherlich pizza und
bier aber richtig interessant wird es
erst wenn man das richtige bier zum
belag der jeweiligen pc
eine pizza quattro voci ist ganz anders
als eine mit prosciutto und pilzen man
muss also verstehen dass jeweils
verschiedene biere dazu passt
langsam wächst dieses bewusstsein
wir treffen ihn erneut in weimar wo er
bier und eiscreme verkaufen lässt
wir haben 600 eiscreme und sorbet sowie
sechs tiere drei aus belgien eines aus
schottland
ich teile gerne mein wissen über bier
und der kultur nicht nur bei
verkostungen sondern auch indem ich
zeige was man damit alles machen kann
am anfang steht das interesse ein
produkt besser kennenzulernen
dann interessiert man sich plötzlich
dafür was man mit mir machen kann
bei verkostungen von stärkeren bieren
mit mehr alkohol kommt schnell die frage
auf wie man sein dir besser genießen
kann und welche speisen sich zu einem
bier anbieten
es geht also nicht mehr nur darum bier
zu trinken sondern es mit passenden
geschmäckern zu kombinieren und zu
genießen
[Musik]
weniger bitter ist die anderen
ja das eis gibt hier den ton an die
mischung mit dem eis neutralisiert das
bittere passt gut zusammen
ja ohne süß zu werden
ich gut
[Musik]
lecker wir brauchen wir passen oder deo
badesalz von shampoo dann riechen die
haare und
das wird noch mein lieblings geschmack
das größte problem für mich bei den
abendveranstaltungen ist die
verfügbarkeit der biere in kleinen bars
und restaurants
die großen industriellen brauereien
spielen auch eine rolle
immer größere interessensgruppen
versuchen mehr verschiedene biere zur
verfügung zu haben als früher
wie trinkt man dieses
aperitif
es ist recht süß deshalb der geschmack
langweilig werden kann
oder man partners mit buschfleisch das
wird auch oft mit früchten serviert
zu unseren braumeister
seit wann wirst du hier seit 2003
der gelernte industrie biologie
techniker jakobowski hat in balerna eine
technologische brauerei aufgebaut die
perfekten der schmale gebäude der
ehemaligen musikschule passt
aktuell stellt die soko visio brauerei
14 verschiedene sorten bier her wo
befinden wir uns in diesem raum stellen
wir neue rezepturen und lagern unsere
zutaten insbesondere unser ganz
spezielles malz und unseren vakuum
versiegelten hopfen im gefrierschrank
die hauptzutaten also
wo finden wir das einfache malt und den
ersten schritt des brauvorgang die mühle
für die gäste
wir haben immer frische gerste weniger
als einen monat alt
und dann landet alles da unten
die mühle ist über das rohr mit der
braustube verbunden dem herzstück der
produktion
alles aufgeteilt
wir haben uns 2013 nach gründlicher
überlegung für diesen standort
entschieden
und alles auf maß fertigen lassen damit
wir das ganze gebäude für die anlage
nutzen können
die entscheidung für dieses system fiel
aufgrund der unvergleichlichen qualität
der stahlteile und der technischen
standards dieses systems
hier lagern die fertigen flaschen bereit
für den verkauf da drüben haben wir
zudem ein paar barrique fässer
auch lagern wir hier alle kontrollproben
bis zum ablaufdatum der charge
wie viele flaschen
etwa 70 oder 80 tausend flaschen und
fässer mit einem gesamtvolumen von 300
bis 350 hektolitern im jahr
die brauereien findet man häufig
barrique fässer aus der weinproduktion
in denen das bier reift
jako ist einer der wenigen interessieren
die im barrique ein besonderes bier
reifen lassen
die idee entstand mit dem ziel ein
säuerliches bier mit spontan gärung
herzustellen nicht so sauer allerdings
wir machen demnach zuerst das fertige
bier in unseren stahl kessel und lassen
es dann im fass reifen
am anfang steht also das gleiche bier
die gleiche gäste
nach der reifung wird es ungefähr tat
aus den fässern in die flaschen
abgefüllt die fässer haben wir von
regionalen wein herstellen
wir waren von anfang an völlig
unabhängig ohne einen vertriebspartner
der uns den rücken stärkt oder andere
unterstützung aus der getränkeindustrie
es gab nur uns an unser produkt
wir wandten uns eine potenzielle partner
wie restaurants und hotels und brachten
bei treffen kostproben mit
wir erklären ihnen dabei unsere
philosophie und erlangten so eine gruppe
feste kunden die direkt von uns
beliefert werden
das hält die lieferkette klotz und
sichert optimale frische und qualität da
wir auch nur soviel herstellen wie
nachgefragt und
eine mikro brauerei aufzubauen macht
einen nicht reich und mit leidenschaft
allein ist es auch nicht getan man muss
verstehen wie man sich dauerhaft auf dem
markt etabliert wer wie thomas lucas der
erfinder des san rocco beers in monza
lonetal außerhalb der städte wohnt hatte
schwer brust
es ist nicht einfach man braucht
leidenschaft und motivation denn man
kann in seinem tal wirklich etwas gutes
tun und es mit exporten bekannter machen
er ist es am liebsten wenn die leute
herkommen
[Musik]
gott mehr betreffen
juni verkauft ihr euer bier
es gibt einige geschäfte die bevorzugt
waren aus tessin verkaufen denen das
regionale sehr am herzen liegt
ich liefere unsere produkte selbst aus
ich kann es mir nicht leisten jemanden
dafür zu bezahlen
morgen beliefere ich die köpperner
kristalina ich muss also bis nach band
red und dann wieder zurück fahren
vortrag wenn ich den verkehr mit
einrechnen muss ich um fünf uhr morgens
los danach muss ich natürlich wie jeden
tag arbeiten
im juni 2018 stimmte die bevölkerung
gegen die nationalpark lugano durch das
getroffen
blieben davon insgesamt unberührt
aber die entwicklung der region kam zum
stillstand
das hat mich sehr getroffen denn ich
liebe unser tag
ich liebe gern hier und gebe dem tal
gerne etwas von wert zurück das den
tourismus zugute kommt
für mich war das eine katastrophe denn
ohne die nationalpark ist es schon
schwierig genug es hätte geholfen
die zukunft eurer produktion ist also
ungewiss ja sie ist definitiv nicht mehr
sicher sie bedeutet für mich einen
arbeitstag von 12 bis 14 stunden und ein
millionär werde ich davon auch nicht es
ist eine leidenschaft für mich und das
nein hat diese leidenschaft etwas
gedämpft
[Musik]
dieser mensch lebt nicht vom die allein
das war es auch luca ferrari er hat
seinen traum verwirklicht und verdient
seinen lebensunterhalt mit seinen zwei
leidenschaften bier und musik er ist
nicht nur braumeister sondern auch dj
für retro musik und bier eine gute
kombination
es passt fantastisch zusammen so sehr
dass ich sie noch gerne vereinen und
verkostungen mit musik anbieten würde
passendes bier zu passende musik
ich könnte hoch fermentierte bier zu
reggae musik empfehlen
pilz zu
bier und nur sie haben viel gemeinsam
und ich meine jetzt nicht nur dass beide
der unterhaltung dienen
und einem luca vielhaber künstler sein
sein studium folgte jedoch einen ganz
anderen weg
[Musik]
mache gerne dir schon in der schule
experimentierte ich lieber mit hefe und
alkoholische gärung als mit reddoxx
reaktionen und dergleichen
ich bin von natur aus neugierig und
trinken nur bier von wasser mal
abgesehen war ein mag ich nicht und so
kam eins zum anderen
inspiration finde ich oft bei regionalen
produkten nation mit lokalen angebot ist
eine sieger strategie
es interessieren keine mälzerei gibt ist
ein echtes tessiner bier schwer zu
machen weil die hauptzutat in der region
nicht mehr gestört wird aber es gibt
hopfen aus dem meer das qatar oder brot
aus dem valle maggia
in ein anderes bier habe ich gerüstet
die kastanien gegeben für das tolle rest
darum
dass kastanien dir dass es damals gab
hatte mir nicht gefallen da fehlte
meinen geschmacksknospen das rauchige
so finde ich meine inspiration
ich habe geschafft was ich mir
vorgenommen hatte
auf der anderen seite mache ich
beispielsweise auch die rest das ist
nicht einfach nur abgelaufenes bier ich
wollte von vornherein die er sich
herstellen das ist er nicht mit bier
verwechseln der einzige bier es sich aus
der sie ja in der schweiz machen die nur
zwei auch interessant ist die
zusammenarbeit mit der mühle in malaysia
in diesem fall für ein obergäriges
kölsch mit gerste und weizen kann man ja
je nach mischung kölsch und weißbier
braun
das hier ist auch in dünner
hier ist ein allerwelts getränk dass
sich auch die ärmsten leisten können
obwohl es auch super teure dinge gibt
die dann 100 franken pro flasche kosten
nur aus dem besten glas getrunken werden
das ist das tolle am bier alle menschen
kein eines gleichermaßen
kannst du das bier erklären es ist toll
wir haben 2014 mit helmen nach deutscher
art angefangen der markt in spanien war
sehr dürftig verbier verbindet menschen
selbst wenn sie aus verschiedenen
ländern stammen in einer brauerei in
mendrisio treffen wir einen spanischen
frau meister
ja gerne mögen die spanier kraft die
gute frage
tun sie aber verglichen mit dem rest
europas ist der markt noch nicht so weit
und wächst noch nicht so wie in
europäischen nachbarstaaten
außerdem hat spanien keine starke
bierkultur
wir arbeiten in italien und sehen zum
ersten mal in der schweiz
wir sind begeistert dass unser produkt
das wir mal so viel sorgfalt herstellen
am ende an weit entfernten orten
getrunken wird
wurde von luca mazzella eingeladen dem
besitzer von neckattack dessen größte
leidenschaft kraft bier ist und der auch
seine kunden dafür zu begeistern weiß
viele bestellen einfach ein bier
ich wollte dann auf die tafel mit
unseren sechs biersorten hinter mir
gegen jahresende kommen noch zwei
weitere sorten dazu
mich bringt das immer in wallung denn
jetzt beginnt der krieg zwischen uns
beiden
er wird in seinem tessiner dialekt
wieder nur ein bier wollen und ich
erwidere dann dass ich ihm beibringen
werde dass es bier in vielen
verschiedenen varianten gibt zeige ihm
was ein bier alles sein kann
im vergangenen jahr hatte ich kunden
über 50 die schwer zu ändern waren weil
die indoktrinierung so tief saß
sie kommen hier suchen sich ein ip oder
staudt aus und diskutieren dann mit mir
welche spanische bier empfiehlst du ich
würde sagen nadia
ich habe bei diesen mischungen aus wein
und bier noch keine gefunden die mich
wirklich von den socken gehauen hätte
was sind deine extremsten wir hier
etwas extremes aktuell habe ich am
nicole
ich hatte schon bier mit vanille da
das cache erinnert mich immer an einem
flammenkuchen
letztes jahr überrascht mich rob green
mit einem gehäuse mit trapani salz und
himbeeren
ich muss sagen an dem abend als das bier
bei uns ankam macht mir gerade moskau
brno und hat die frische himbeeren da
wir fügten ganze oder parierte hin
behindert sein es war lustig und
schmeckt gut
einen monat später konnten wir das
gleiche bier nicht mehr trinken
es hatte sich weiterentwickeln
wie zum beispiel schmeckt nach einem
drei oder fünf jahren anders heute soll
alles immer gleich schmecken niemand
will experimentieren wirft uns doch
sachen ausprobieren nicht nur das
produkt sondern auch die menschen kennen
lernen und somit mehr offenheit durchs
leben gehen
[Musik]
unser nächstes dir gefunden
zwei vögel wegen dem hersteller
[Gelächter]
das spiel der abenddämmerung sunset
reichhaltig mit klaren karamell aroma-
und zitrusnoten aus amerikanischen und
regionalen hopfen
aus australien
7 getreide und sieben bis zehn
hopfensorten
da gibt es viel zu entdecken dem widmen
wir uns nächstes mal
das merken wir
lesezeichen
fertig
[Applaus]
[Musik]